hey there welcome back to the channel my
name is Andrew Clark and in today's
video I wanted to take some time to talk
about how you can link your chords
together using lead lines or single
notes now there are a whole bunch of
different ways to go about doing this
and it's all going to depend on the way
that you look at the fretboard the chord
shapes that you're most comfortable
using and the little bit of theory
knowledge that you already have but
today we're mostly going to be focusing
on one method for doing this and it's
mostly just based on the chord road maps
that you've learned in previous videos
of mine so if you haven't seen that
video of mine yet I'll make sure to link
it down in the description so you can go
check it out before proceeding with this
lesson so I've seen a lot of other
people on YouTube teaching this and what
they'll do is they'll teach you a
handful of licks that you kind of need
to memorize and then you can take those
licks and use them in a specific part of
a specific chord progression the problem
is this doesn't really give you much
variety and realistically you don't want
to be playing the same lick over the
same change every single time over and
over again so what I want to do here is
instead of just giving you a bunch of
fish I'd rather teach you how to fish
it's important to know as well that a
lot of people that learn this concept
learn it using the blues and while the
blues is great it does kind of lock you
into specific sounds and specific chord
progressions so what we're doing here
pretty much Works across every
contemporary genre it's more focused on
pop chord progressions Rock chord
progressions country worship music uh
and things like that with that out of
the way let's get into it okay so we're
gonna kick things off with the two chord
road maps that you're probably already
familiar with from my other videos and
basically all they are is we've got two
of them one is rooted on the low E
string one is rooted on the a string and
what that really means is the root note
is the note that shares the name of the
key so if we're in the key of G major
the root note would be a g for the key
of C major the root note would be a c
this note is also commonly called the
tonic of the key so the first roadmap
rooted on the low E string looks like
this from the key of G major we find our
G note which is right there and then
we've got our one which is G two which
is a three which is B four which is C 5
which is D 6 which is e and then we've
got our seven which is an F sharp right
up there and then for our second chord
road map if we're in the key of C rather
than finding a C note up here and having
to play way up the fretboard instead
we're going to find it on the a string
and that is right here so one right here
is C two is D then 3 is up here at e
then we go all the way down onto the low
E string for four which is f five which
is a g six which is an A and then for
seven up here we've got a B now what
that does is it covers the root notes of
all of our diatonic chords inside of
each key then with each of those root
notes we have a major minor or
diminished chord that goes along with
each one and that kind of makes up our
chord road maps like I said if you're a
little bit confused here you can head
into the description and check out that
other video where I go into this stuff
in a little bit more detail but
everything up until this point should be
pretty straightforward okay so for the
next step what we're going to do is
we're just going to add a few more no
notes to our chord road maps and since
all of the notes inside the key are
already covered it's just repeats of
notes that are already there just kind
of filling out the space so that we can
kind of access everything so I'm going
to go into the key of D major for this
one D major or B minor same key a string
root chord road map start with our D
note here we've got D E F sharp let me
go down here and we've got g a b and c
sharp but what we're going to do is
we're just going to add a few other
places where we can play some of these
same notes just to fill out the space a
little bit so what that means is here's
our D and we can actually go back and
put a 7 right here so a C sharp right
here we can go back we can put a b here
so a six here so
same note C sharp
right there we're even going to add
another d
right there and then we're going to go
lower here so we've got our four here we
can actually put our three so our F
sharp we can put that down here and then
we can keep going up here as well so as
we've got one two three we can even put
a four up here so this one here
same note they're just different octaves
but they are both Gene notes and what
this does is it essentially gives us a
scale we can improvise with don't get
scared of the word improvise I promise
it's super simple but it gives us a
bunch of notes that we can play around
with in between our chords and because
all of these chords are diatonic to the
key of D major all of them while they're
not all going to sound equally as good
as one another they're all gonna work
and instead of going chord then release
the chord and go up and play some licks
and then go back down to a chord and
then go up and play some licks in a new
spot which can be a little bit trickier
to get the hang of what we're going to
do is we're going to use these lower
notes to kind of Riff in between our
chord changes now if you don't have your
chords super tight if you're not super
comfortable changing between especially
Barre chord shapes this is going to be a
little bit challenging and I think in
general if you're not super confident
with your chord changes I wouldn't jump
into playing stuff between your chord
changes because ultimately this is kind
of on top of the foundation of changing
cores hitting the cords in the right
spot is always going to be more
important and more effective and it's
going to serve the music better so let's
start off with a chord progression let's
do a one six four five in the key of D
major so that's a D major to a B minor
to a G major to an a major we're gonna
do it nice and slow and all I'm gonna do
is I'm gonna pick some random notes
between the changes and I'm just going
to kind of let my ear do its thing
there's no rules as long as the notes
are in the key some are going to sound
better than others but we're just going
to try it out so it'll sound something
like this
[Music]
foreign
and the only real rule for doing
something like this is when you're
playing in a band make sure that you
come down when the rest of the band does
the change so wherever that lands if
it's on the one or if it's a push and
it's early whatever that is just make
sure you're hitting that and then the
rest of the time you can kind of start
fooling around and trying some other
things your sense of Rhythm here is
incredibly important so don't go too
crazy with it focus on landing on those
chords in the right spot and when you
feel like you've got a little space
you've got a little time throw an extra
note two notes a little slide up or down
just using these notes from the roadmap
now I know this is probably sounding a
little bit simple but this is the best
place to start if you want to start
playing some more impressive licks where
you maybe start going on to the higher
strings this does lead to that it's not
like this is the thing that stands alone
there are a whole bunch of places you
can go once you've got this foundation
and I am going to get into that a little
later in this video but before we do
that we need to talk about the other
roadmap app which is roadmap number one
which we're doing second but it's the
first roadmap which is rooted on the low
E string because we can do something
very similar and what we're going to do
is we're going to find G is a great key
for this because you should be
comfortable with it already uh we've got
one two three four five six seven and we
can fill that out again we can go one
two three we can get a four here
like that we can get a three right here
we can even get a seven here
and that's an octave right the same note
just options of each other then we can
carry on even higher if we want we can
go from six seven we can go all the way
up to our one again so an octave of our
G
and then right here's our four there's
our five and if you wanted to you could
even build that second road map again on
top of this link them together from the
root note here on the G we're not going
to do that today but it basically allow
you to cover the whole fretboard of all
the notes in the key of G which is
pretty cool and now we've got a good
chunk of our fretboard available to us
depending on the chord we're playing
what's close by everything should be
comfortable and we'll find a new chord
progression in this key and we're just
going to do the exact same thing we did
with the first roadmap so for a chord
progression in this key let's do a five
six four one in the key of G major so
that's D major E minor C major and then
down to a G major and all we're going to
be doing is linking those chords
together using the notes from our little
extended roadmap and it should sound
something like this
[Music]
thank you
so now that you got both road maps
figured out you can really play in any
key all you have to do is shift the
roadmaps up or down the fretboard so
that that root note lines up with the
key of the song and then you're just
choosing whichever roadmap feels the
most comfortable for you for that key so
from here really honestly the rest is up
to you the point is to kind of start
improvising coming up with stuff on the
Fly using the notes that you're allowed
to play inside the key think about
Rhythm think about where you're placing
the notes think about how many notes
you're playing are you repeating notes
those are all things that you have the
freedom to try out and then once you get
comfortable with that you can start
moving into some of the more advanced
concepts so if you're feeling like this
is a little bit challenging for you
already you can feel free to stop here
the stuff that we've covered so far is
going to be a great foundation for
building this skill and there's a whole
bunch of like I said a whole bunch of
different ways that you can go from here
but we are going to get into things now
that are a little bit more noodly based
more on vertical scale so rather than
being always horizontal we can get a
little more vertical but like I said if
this already feels like enough you can
feel free to stop here okay so for our
next step we are going to start getting
into the higher strings uh this can kind
of become a little overwhelming quickly
uh so feel free to take this nice and
slow but I do have to give you a little
bit of context and this probably should
make sense to you already but if we
wanted to we could actually take our
road maps and extend them onto every
single string all the way up and down
the fretboard and basically just get all
of our notes that naturally occur inside
of a key so if I was in the key of G
major I'd have all of my notes and then
to play in other Keys the intervals or
the shapes themselves wouldn't change I
would just slide it up and down just
like the roadmaps already like I said
we're not going to get into all that
instead what we're going to do is we're
going to start looking vertically we're
going to look at Scales now there are a
whole bunch of ways we can approach this
because there's scale shapes all over
the fretboard and it just comes down to
which scale shapes you are most
comfortable with but what I like to do
is build myself a little bit of a home
base around position one of the minor
pentatonic scale so to make this easy
for you to visualize what we're going to
do is we're going to play this in a key
that's very comfortable so it's going to
be the key of D major we're going to do
is we're going to use our a string root
note roadmap we've got all of our notes
like this
now something you might not have noticed
is we actually have our minor pentatonic
scale right here for this key so if I
played
foreign
[Music]
thank you
so do you kind of see how they fit
together basically what we're doing is
we're taking our six chord so that minor
six chord in the key of D major and the
bar chord shape for that is going to
look like this
which is something you should be
familiar with just a minor bar chord
shape and if you look closely you can
see it kind of already outlines our
minor pentatonic scale which is right
here
[Music]
foreign
scale is is it's just a major or minor
scale with two notes removed and those
notes are the four and the seven of the
key so this note here are seven and this
note here are four we leave those out of
our pentatonic scale what you can
actually do is you can actually add the
four and the Seven back into the
pentatonic scale shape and what happens
is it just becomes a regular minor or
major scale depending on the note you
start on so it's all the same notes that
we've used from our chord roadmap
instead it's just laid out vertically uh
so we would be starting here on our six
but basically we'd get six seven one
two three four
five six seven
one two three four five six seven one
so you don't need to memorize the
numbers here that go along with this
shape that's not what I'm trying to do
here this isn't a new roadmap like that
basically what I'm just showing you
though is that all of those notes that
we talked about horizontally also exist
in this scale shape that's kind of
easier to play because it's all in one
spot so you don't have to slide your
hand around now what that does for us is
that gives us the freedom to play any of
those notes while we play a chord
progression in that key so always basing
our scale shape off of that sixth chord
that minor chord so whatever key we're
in wherever we move this when we hit
that six minor chord we know
[Music]
and you can even add those extra notes
into this scale shape if you want as
well and play around with those the only
thing is the pentatonic scale exists
like that for a reason the fourth and
the seventh scale degree uh they tend to
not always sound as good with certain
chords the rest of the remaining five
pentatonic notes they pretty much sound
good over any chord in the key so
they're just like the safest of the safe
notes but play around with the other one
ones too like I said there really aren't
any rules here so now we're gonna do is
we're gonna play a chord progression and
we're going to use our same chord road
map to kind of use those bass notes to
move around but now we also have access
to this other vertical spot as well now
this might mean you have to jump around
a little bit or maybe when you're down
on your four chord you're not going to
jump up here and riff and go back
depending on how quick you are at
jumping up and down the fretboard but
I'm just going to kind of show you again
the type of thing that you can do so
let's grab another chord progression
let's do a four one five six so in the
key of D major that gives us G Major D
major a major and B minor and all I'm
going to do is use the root notes from
my chord road map as well as my new
minor pentatonic scale shape I'm just
going to kind of combine them and just
see what I come up with
[Music]
thank you
okay so that should give you a little
bit of an idea of what you can do with
this stuff if you want to play in
different Keys the whole thing stays the
same we just shift it up or down the
fretboard uh really we're just
scratching the surface with this one
scale shape and then the chord road map
there's a whole bunch more you could do
obviously there's other scale shapes
over top of every other chord if I'm
playing the G down here in this key it's
a little unrealistic to jump all the way
up here and play a pentatonic lick with
this other shape because it's so far
away and especially if the chords are
moving quickly becomes really
challenging so what you would do is you
learn the shapes that kind of sit in
that position which is just rearranging
the exact same notes it's just a new
shape in a new spot so if I was playing
the G down here
foreign
[Music]
and then when I go to the a there's a
shape there too
[Music]
you kind of get the idea there's all
these other spots that you can play the
same thing as but I really just wanted
to kind of scratch the surface and just
kind of get you off on the right foot
with looking at the fretboard this way
and kind of thinking about licks in this
way and you might be thinking about the
other chord road map because we did this
based on the a string root note what if
it was a g string root note well this
pentatonic scale shape fits in there as
well let's say we're in the key of a
major so this is our roadmap one two
three four five six seven well the
pentatonic scale shape the exact same
shape that can be used the same way is
just down here so this is the one right
you remember back to the other shape
this was the one this is the six so
we've got
[Music]
and if we wanted to add those extra
notes
and those would be all of our allowable
notes inside of this key which is a
military or F sharp minor now obviously
this is going to feel a little
restrictive right now because you've
only got that one shape but as you get
comfortable with it you can kind of
start extending that little home base
out and then no matter what chord you're
on there's always going to be kind of a
shape nearby that's going to be very
comfortable to play but you really do
want to start slow and really Master
this one shape first before you kind of
break out into those other ones okay so
that's going to do it for this video I
just kind of wanted to give you guys an
intro into this whole concept of playing
licks and single notes in between your
chords if you guys want to keep going
with this series and kind of extend into
these new shapes and try some new ideas
please make sure you leave a comment
below and let me know if you guys
enjoyed this video please give it a
thumbs up and please also consider
subscribing to the channel as well I
release a new guitar video every single
week and with all that said thank you so
much for watching and I will see you in
the next one
[Music]
thank you